[موسيقى]
كل عام
وفود والعديد من شد الرحال والباصات
والحافلات الى المسجد الاقصى لتزيينه
وتنظيف ساحاته استعدادا واستقبالا لشهر
رمضان حصيله الحافلات لهذا العام 186
حافله الحمد لله رب العالمين فيها العديد
من النساء والاطفال والشباب وحتى الشيوخ
شاركونا في هذا اليوم العظيم المبارك نحن
اعتدنا كل عام بدعم اهلنا في الداخل
الفلسطيني
ليلبوا النداء ويهب لدعم الاقتصاد المقدسي
ايضا فنحن نوجه الناس لشراء اغراضهم
الرمضانيه من هنا من بيت المقدس
[موسيقى]
على الاحتلال ان يغلق عنا نيرانو وحكده ان
يلزم قطعان المستوطنين الذين يقتحمون هذا
المكان لينغصوا علينا العبادات نعم نريد
لهذا الشهر ان يكون شهر عباده تعظيم لله
عز وجل ان ناتي بامن وامان نؤدي شعائر دين
الحنيف ناتي الى مسجدنا يعني هم الدخلاء
على هذا المكان من الطبيعي للانسان المسلم
ان ياتي لمسده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]